[Música]
[Aplausos]
decía platón
la música da alma al universo alas a la
mente vuelos a la imaginación
y consuelo a la tristeza
soy un santo que soy licenciado en
música soy maestro de yoga y me dedico a
la musicoterapia
doy conciertos de sanación y visitó a
enfermos en sus casas o también toco en
escuelas a los niños toco invadiendo
espacios públicos causando diferentes
atmósferas
y siempre he dirigido a
a conectar con cada uno de nosotros en
nuestro interior
así lo sencillo desde muy pequeño yo
sabía que quería hacer música sabía que
quería estar cerca del espíritu no sé
era un hambre de de buscar algo más
sutil algo que nos conecta que nos
también nos nos nos llena de divinidad
y bueno pues llegar a este punto no ha
sido nada fácil porque pues yo trabajaba
en la orquesta profesional de la
universidad auto
autónoma de chihuahua
y llegar a este punto también pues me
había costado había sido 15 años de
estudio
con un instrumento on y violín
cuando ya estaba allí yo pensaba que era
lo que quería lograr profesionalmente
pues si estaba en un punto
y muy bueno pero sentía todavía que me
hacía falta algo que es una libertad que
es una inspiración
y bueno
una de mis mayores inspiraciones fueron
las investigaciones de masaru emoto un
japonés que investigó el agua y sus
cristales
encontró
cómo
a través de la vibración de la música
del pensamiento de la palabra nuestra
realidad puede cambiar
recientemente me preguntaron en tus
conciertos que es lo que sana tu música
y fue una muy buena pregunta porque
también me hizo replantearme a mí la
situación y yo descubrí que la música
que yo hago es solamente mi
manifestación igual que cualquier otra
cosa que tú puedas crear es una
manifestación
y tiene un impacto pero más allá de lo
que de lo que sea en palabras de lo que
sea en hechos deja una resonancia y
eso es lo que realmente es lo que los
demás sienten con lo que los demás se
quedan
más allá del lenguaje es más allá es
algo más sublime es el espíritu
dios es un gran misterio y siempre se
está revelando a través de todos a
través de la creación a través de ti a
través de mí y en mis conciertos
entonces está sanación viene de otra
realidad divina de otra realidad
espiritual de una realidad
que a lo mejor puede ser un misterio
pero con mi música yo potencial hizo
que las personas pueden sentarse o
acostarse y disfrutar relajarse y
encontrar
en su cuerpo relajado y en sus emociones
equilibradas su sanación porque esa es
el principio de nuestra salud
toda la enfermedad viene de una
de una tensión de emociones que no
sabemos a dónde canalizar pero todos
tenemos dentro de nosotros ese mensaje
especial del alma que está ahorita
encarnada en ti
entonces mi música no es solamente para
gente que necesite sanar sino para todos
porque todos necesitamos siempre volver
a estar en contacto con nuestro interior
realmente estar cumpliendo lo que
debemos de transmitir en esta vida
y bueno
ahora voy a tocar un poco de mi música
y pues espero que te relajes un momento
y sólo contempla observa porque también
esa experiencia estética
es un momento sublime que te acerca un
poco a la eternidad
[Música]
y
bien
[Música]
y
en el tiempo
[Música]
e
i
[Música]
ah
e
[Música]
i
y
[Música]
bueno
sí
[Música]
y
por qué
[Música]
y
[Risas]
[Música]
[Aplausos]